hi i'm dave baker and these are some of
the best african weapons from forged in
fire
now many african cultures consider their
bladesmiths mystics imbuing magical
powers into the weapons they created
these weapons were often what are
considered anthropomorphic they have
features of humans in them and were
considered a part of the warrior
this weapon
is the nambe nulu the nambe nulu is also
called the executioner sword or the
nagala you can see this intimidating
curve on there it's a fascinating shape
for a weapon
this weapon can be traced back to the
[ __ ] ethnic group of northern congo
now throughout the congo african smiths
worked in iron and basic steels and many
of their blades are forged into these
fanciful shapes shapes from nature or
anthropomorphic shapes imitating the
human form
many european explorers coming back from
africa
brought back stories about the
executions that were carried out by the
people of the congo
though they did take the heads of their
enemies the fanciful stories of european
explorers might be a bit exaggerated
there are many many different styles of
this blade
all of them have just these beautiful
sweeping curves and just an intimidating
look
[Music]
this weapon
is the sanggizi now this is the weapon
of the kardi people from northern
cameroon and eastern nigeria this was a
throwing weapon but it's equally good as
a slasher it's actually sharp on all the
angles back of the blade the inside of
the blade
these weapons were usually carried two
or three behind the shield so you had
multiples you could get behind your
shield throw these weapons in an
opponent or get up close and use it in
your hand as a close combat weapon
now the african weapons are often
separated into two categories a circular
weapon or an f weapon you can see that
this is sort of the f-shaped weapon
giving you multiple points of contact
and multiple bladed surfaces now i don't
know about you but if somebody threw
this at me
i'd be running the other direction
so this leaf-bladed beauty is the ida
the primary weapon of the yoruba people
of west africa now iron work goes back
in africa as far as the 6th century bc
and was the primary reason for the rise
of the yoruba people
the ida is an important symbol in the
aruba culture as a rites of passage as
well as taking oaths and sacrifices
these long light leaf bladed weapons
make for wonderful choppers whether
you're cutting brush or attacking an
opponent
they're fast they're easy to use you can
see the handle is relatively small but
it fits the hand beautifully the weight
is all up in the head making for really
good chopping and thrusting as well
that's a
great light
super fast weapon
[Music]
now this wickedly curved weapon is the
shotel this is the weapon of the
abyssinian people of ancient ethiopia
you can see that made curves very
intimidating but it wasn't a very good
slashing weapon it could be used to
reach around a shield and actually hook
an opponent or reach over the top
stabbing into an opponent
you can see it's a rather undecorated
weapon unlike many of the african
weapons that are highly decorated
engraved you can see they're following
the sickle shape basically agricultural
tools that were turned to weapons
now though this isn't the most practical
weapon i certainly wouldn't want to face
one
[Music]
this beautiful short spear is the zulu
iqua now the iqua was basically a
shortened acid guy spear with the the
shaft cut down now you might think this
a throwing weapon but it's not it's
actually a thrusting weapon it was used
in an underhand fashion to literally
slide out of the hand and stop making it
a short stabbing thrust from behind a
shield
this was the primary weapon for the zulu
during the anglo-zulu war of 1879 in
south africa the name iqa supposedly
comes from the sound it makes as it
enters and leaves the body
that's a scary name for a weapon
[Music]
well there you have it folks some of the
deadliest african weapons seen on forged
and fire if you have any questions or
suggestions leave them in the comment
section and we'll try to get to them in
future videos
you